شركه تويتر تواجه دعوى قضائيه من قبل شركه
كراون العقاريه التابعه للعائله الملكيه
البريطانيه بسبب تخلفها عن دفع الايجار
المستحق لمقر عملها السابق في هذا المبنى
هنا في بيكاديمي في وسط لندن هذه الدعوه
القضائيه ليست الاولى من نوعها يعني طبعا
شركه تويتر تواجه اربع دعاوي على الاقل في
الولايات المتحده حول المشكله ذاتها وهي
دفع ايجار مكاتب تويتر طبعا هذه الدعوه
تاتي بعد انفصل الماسك نصف القوه العامله
للشركه بهذا خفض التكاليف وهو ما دفع
الشركه بالفعل الى همم يعني ترك هذا المقر
همم فهذا المبنى هو واحد من بين المئات من
المباني التي تملكها شركه تكراون العقاريه
وهي اكبر ملاك ل همم الاراضي هنا في
بريطانيا تولد ارباحا للخزينه البريطانيه
يعود حوالي 15% منها الى العائله الملكيه
على بريطانيا من لندن عروب عبد الحق علي
العربيه